然而我特意整理了一些，
我认为对大家来说，
在选择伴侣的时候，
一定要去带着这个问题去求证，
带着这个问题去一点一点的去核实，
带着这个思维，
但凡你怀疑，
但凡你恐惧，
但凡有这样的很大的可能性的时候，
就不要轻易走入下一步。
第一个你先去查一下我国目前换HIV的人口总数，
你自己去算一下，
大概多少人当中会有一个人是患HIV的，
我认真的查了一下，
我们国家现在HIV的确诊的总数大概130万左右，
划下来的话，
1000个人里面有一个人是HIV的患病者，
那这1000个人当中，
你要排出去小孩，
排出去十几岁的小孩，
你要排出去那种他本身就不太可能犯这个病的那一群人，
那也就是说，
在我们这一些18岁成年到五六十岁的，
这个就是有伴侣啊，
有这方面行为的这些人当中，
可能几百个人当中就有一个，
所以以后你们不管跟谁谈恋爱的话，
首先带着这样一个疑问去求证。
怎么求证，
最简单粗暴的方法就是一起去抽血去求证他是不是HHIV的这个患病者，
这个是第一个，
第二个你们去查一下我国目前精神分裂的人口总数去查，
我昨天晚上查了之后，
他没有一个确切的完全的这样一个统计，
只是根据各方的，
就是不那么权威的统计来说的话，
打底800万划下来的话是6‰，
1000个人里面有六个人是精神分裂，
然后你刨出去不可能跟你结婚的那些，
不可能跟你处对象的那些，
比如你刨出去，
45岁以上的刨出去，
嗯，
18岁以下的，
那可不是6‰的概念。
大家能理解龙飞姐讲的这个逻辑吗？
从总人口上来算6‰，
但是你刨出去那些你根本不可能找他结婚的对象的话，
那可不是6‰的概念。
好，
第三个，
你去给我查一下，
这个社会上总人口当中无良症患者的比例是多少？
无良症是什么意思？
他没有良知，
他伤害你，
他不会觉得自己有错，
他骂你，
他也不会觉得自己有错，
他永远都不会同情你，
我会可怜你，
你在他面前就是每一滴血都流干了，
他也不会为之动容，
他也不会愧疚，
他也不会后悔，
什么都没有，
那还叫无良症，
这是三类人了，
对不对？
第4类人，
如果你本身非常想要小孩子，
非常想当母亲，
那么你去查一下无精症患者在整个社会当中，
他占总人口，
他占比是多少？
无精症，
弱精症你都去查，
那也就意味着什么，
如果你想跟一个人步入婚姻，
如果你本人很想当妈妈，
很想当母亲，
那么你在步入婚姻，
领那张结婚证之前，
你先去做一个体检，
看看她是不是弱精，
是不是无精，
不然的话，
你想要做妈妈，
你就且等着，
各种各样的什么胎平，
各种各样的什么流产，
还不一定做试管，
她不一定能做成啊，
折腾死你。
第5类你去。
给我查一下反社会人格所占的人口，
总人口的那个总数占的比例，
反社会人格是什么意思？
那玩意儿比无良症更可怕。
第6，
你再去给我查自恋型人格。
占的比重是多大？
自恋性人格，
那说白了，
这一辈子你跟他在一起，
他无论如何你对他多好，
他都觉得理所当然，
他觉得他能看上你就是你的荣幸，
他觉得他跟你在一起就是一种恩赐，
他觉得他这辈子不可能做错一件事，
不可能说错一一句话，
你们俩关系处不好，
一定是你的问题，
去给我查，
到底占比是多少，
再去给我查。
偏执型人格，
偏执型人格那玩意也挺恐怖的，
他要干什么，
你就非得按照他的那个节奏来，
他如果挤牙刷，
挤牙膏，
他得从下面往上挤的话，
那你就非得这么干，
他认为哪件事情啊是对的，
哪怕全世界的人都认为是错的，
他也得这么干。
啊，
偏执型人格8，
你再去查强迫型人格，
查一下占比是多少，
第9个特别核心，
特别关键的，
今天就去给我查全国的经量经验人数是多少，
我在这里我真诚的跟大家讲，
龙飞姐，
我本人我并不不排斥，
我对男生喜欢男孩子，
女生喜欢女孩子这件事情，
我我就尊重，
但是我憎恨的是哪种人，
憎恨的是他明明喜欢的是男的，
他就骗你，
骗你跟他结婚，
骗你跟他生孩子，
完了之后他不碰你，
他让你觉得是你没有魅力，
他让你觉得是你有什么问题，
那到最后他才不碰你了，
什么锅都甩给你。
你这样人我跟你讲啊，
在我直播间出现过不下10个案例，
10个号都打不住，
20个都打不住，
你们都去给我查啊，
查总总人口占多少，
今天嗯，
再有你们再去给我查一个数据。
就是我们全中国的女性当中，
在婚姻当中最佳比例是多少？
去查，
基本上约等于20%~30%的女性在婚姻当中是要遭遇这些的。
再去查几个数据，
酒精依赖就是你去查一下酒蒙子占人口比重是多少，
再去查，
我成瘾我沉瘾的人占多少再去查，
沉迷游戏的人占多少再去查。
低的比例，
比例是多少？
好一通给我查完了之后，
一项一项的去排除，
一项一项的去看，
你现在谈的这个对项有没有可能是其中的一项，
学会了吗？
刚刚有个同学说，
哎，
王菲姐，
你要这么搞的话，
你是什么意思？
我是什么意思？
我希望你们都幸福，
我希望你们不要遭遇这些，
我是什么意思？
能理解龙飞姐吗？
刚刚有的人说根本没有多少完美的人，
我不求大家找到完美的人，
我但求你们找个正常人。
可以吗？
我不求你们说找一个完美的人。
我但求你们学会这一套方法去排除，
我但求你们找个正常的人，
就是找个哪怕是一只小狗下了狗崽子半夜叫了，
他也会不忍心，
也会起来给喂，
喂个水，
喂个奶，
我但求你们找的是这样的正常人，
而不是那种生完孩子的时候半夜起来，
你要是吵醒他了，
他啪给你一耳巴子，
你别找这样的人行吗？
能理解龙菲姐想表达这个意思吗？
就是我不求你们找那种什么完美的伴侣，
就但求你们通过这些数据，
通过这些方法，
通过这些我刚刚讲的这些东西，
你一项一项去筛选，
但求你们找个正常人就行。